[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts so
I am a dumb [ __ ]
How can I
not be so stupid and keep my husband I
want to keep him happy and I think all
the women listening to they want to know
the secrets
I'm writing them down I'll tell you the
secrets
yeah go ahead I'm taking it I I don't
think most women understand what men are
looking for in general from life okay
and it is not just relationships it's in
general from life if you want to keep
your man happy you need to think how do
I make my man look better to the world
how do I make him look better in front
of other men you know what if I were to
just make him two coffees and shut the
[ __ ] up yeah he's gonna look like the
big G and he's going to be in love with
me that's what you have to do as a woman
well let me let me just stop you real
quick and say something you got a lot of
work to do
me yeah I brought you two coffees this
morning because because you were coming
in and I said Tommy here's your two
coffees I'm just saying he made a lot of
sense and what do you [ __ ] just I'm
just saying keep taking notes don't even
talk to me do you ever get in a fight
with your girl then just tape it up for
an hour
you don't do that over tape
you got to go swipe on some tape bro
that's it
that's his whole thing I think that was
him as a kickboxer
funny you can't even act like a guy not
funny
it's fun funny bro put a girl's body
count on her forehead solve all the
problems in the world
bang out the machete boom in the face
and grip her by the neck shut up [ __ ]
um what's he doing there cutting your
head off
uh he's just describing uh how he would
attack a female partner if she ever uh
accused him of cheating and he goes it's
bang out the machete boom in her face
and grip her by the neck like you gotta
threaten her she got it right up next to
her oh but if my whole thing is if he
didn't cheat and she's accusing him of
cheating how's he supposed to respond
foreign
well done that's your legacy yeah well
done man yeah there's always going to be
a place on the internet for guys
explaining to incels that they can't get
labeled
like uh this guy uh the Netflix
documentary that they've just done the
most hated man on the Internet it's
literally Andrew Tate but like 10 years
ago it's not the first time we've seen
this this guy was it uh I'll use are you
up.com or whatever yeah this is Andrew
Taylor it's the same guy now now that
being said you're not even original at
least be original you're true you know
what I mean this is a red pill most
people don't want to accept but if any
man if you were to get any man on the
planet and say to him you have a wife
and she loves you and she's gonna remain
loyal to you and you can still [ __ ]
around with other women do you want that
yes or no if any man's honest he's gonna
say yes
yes oh my God
[Laughter]
the game every every he tries to make
he'll be like if I get a new car yeah
and leave it in the garage and someone
try it and you know these kids are like
oh yeah it's so simple yeah all you have
to do is talk about it in terms of Lambo
yeah now I get it like it's so funny
like women are not Cars dude
well no no
I was like I wish they were yeah yeah be
careful careful with that analogy yeah I
wish I could be married to a car no I'm
just the I'm just the neurodivergent one
who takes it literally run into agitated
a coffee shop it's like it's my
girlfriend it's just a car yeah yeah
he's like what I'm like yeah you told me
you said
you know if anyone were to get in it I'd
be upset like absolutely you know I'm
afraid that you're looking at her right
now
I don't want to like drive away my dog
Marshall have you ever met Marshall yeah
sweetest [ __ ] animal that's ever
existed all he wants to do is love
everybody oh no I did meet him yeah
everybody's his friend yeah yeah but
he's an ancestor of a wolf yeah they've
turned him into this thing through
thousands of years of breeding is that
what just like they're trying to do to
men exactly yeah that's what they're
trying to do where's Andrew Tate when
you need it
femininity [ __ ] or masculinity toxic
femininity is right that was a Freudian
slip but toxic masculinity what that
means is like Oh you mean the men who
carved the world yes now you don't need
them yeah so now you want to get rid of
them but you do need them you just don't
think you need them because you don't
need them right now and then Russia has
China is making a more China's making
them more masculine the bigger you get
the more of a Target you become and
listen I'm not saying Andrew Tate is
you know I don't think he should be the
go-to for I think young guys listening
to him probably will get some bad ideas
in their head but these young people
often have bad ideas in their head and
good ideas in their head and they sort
them out as they get older this is not
new
none of this is new I had bad ideas in
my head when I grew up and you know who
they were from my parents
it you know now there's people on the
internet that can influence people for
sure but there's a lot of other people
that can influence you too positively
negatively
I don't see any rule the ruling is gavel
put him back on social media please I
don't see any reason
holding the machete to someone's neck if
that's a problem well I don't know get
me out of here
he didn't do it he said it
yeah I'll put a machete to someone's I
mean that's hypothetically speaking he
would do such a thing if he said if
right X then y
if I'm accused of cheating I'll use the
machete
but he's not really gonna do it
probably a goof
it's a joke I don't know never before
has this happened in history a guy that
lives in Romania and does what he does
there which is on casinos apparently has
slaves that's crazy
that you can't escape the allegation
female sex slaves
oh that makes it better I don't know
what it is
I don't know the rules for Romania my
point is he is showing up on my feed
nine [ __ ] stop dude I'm not clicking
on it it's just next video is him in
that accent which I don't know what the
[ __ ] country is I'll be trying to figure
that [ __ ] out too God damn it bro it's a
Non-Stop yeah so cap you cook it on
every single video
face right now this is kind of
impressive he's like people are cutting
up my videos and then misrepresenting me
and he's like there's no way that I
can't be misrepresented so I'm gonna
like stop putting out anything until I
can figure out how to like a way around
not being misrepresented and but then
also you're like you're not so I'm I'm
sure sometimes you're misrepresented but
also some of those clips are well no
because yeah you kind of like for
example the big ones that go viral like
the women not driving or whatever like
you said that on like five projects
exactly right like that was like a
talking a talking point it was like a
bit yeah which like it's one yeah which
is funny you're like why why is that
worthy of you getting kicked off exactly
internet 100 that's crazy so that was do
you but do you think like to what degree
is it uh conspiracy where like a guy
from YouTube and a guy from Facebook or
like I don't think it's a guy but
at Facebook or YouTube no I don't think
it was a guy
that was behind this no no I'm saying
I'm sure they've had a meeting at at
these companies is it under is it where
they go hey this guy's under a bridge
like a bunch of like a one Facebook guy
one executive one Tinder guy one like
one Rumble guy shows that they go you
weren't invited to this he goes yeah
you're right I'll see myself
you know what so many women say to me
you're so Andrew you know what you're so
rich but you're smart and you're
actually very intelligent and I know
you'd get really bored of like a robot
and I'm sitting there thinking [ __ ] I
wish to God you were a robot
[Laughter]
star signs oh yeah I'm so glad tell me
more about by Sagittarius Rising you
idiot there's no such thing as too
submissive there's no such thing I'm
never gonna look at a beautiful woman
who does everything I say and go you
know what you do too much of what I say
I want to go get some disagreeable [ __ ]
yeah exactly on one planet but let me
tell you what you're saying if there's
truth to it and judging by my husband's
reaction listen we've had world famous
comedians sit across from him he's never
spit coffee out of his notes like he
just did for you it's because it's it's
like you know what it is sometimes you
see these videos of these guys that are
lost and then they walk into a church
and then the the preacher says like the
exact right thing from the Bible and the
guy's like oh my God I this is what I
needed I feel the same way right now I
feel like I love to hear that friend I
love to hear that thank you really good
to have you here and speaking speaking
if I could be I don't know to borrow
from them I think you're kind of
speaking the gospel right now why do you
think that you got under her skin
because we're very good at what we do
like we we we
psychoanalyze people with like minimal
effort like you know you could like this
is a guy who missed a few hugs of his
mother I think we can all agree there's
a man there because my mother was a
judge your mom about how he talks about
his mother and women in general will
fold suit as well right
she's getting good yeah and and so she
should man so she should yeah
this guy missed a few hugs clearly and
um it's a sad set of Affairs you know I
mean if that if if Mrs tear it [ __ ]
I'm sorry you're gonna give us a second
to laugh at this guy
bro
just because my mom is Scottish and
doesn't hug as much she left you on a
swing one time
she did leave me on a swing and I got a
rash but it is what it is okay I forgive
they seem like they're removing people
with whom
they have
underlying ideological differences and
they're just trying to figure out how to
get rid of them
and again I'm not
joining Hustler's University I won't be
signing up
but I don't think you should this guy
should be removed
I don't you know
what is like do they even tell anyone
why well they just say you're a
misogynist but then they don't like the
thing is they don't link you to the
specific thing but wasn't he a
misogynist a month ago when he was on
too like this is what I don't understand
what's changed
why can't a misogynist talk
I don't understand
he thinks let's say he thinks men are
better than women let's say he that has
that belief I mean I don't know it can
should he not be able to say anything
you know
I I'm just
I'm unmoved
people will counter his belief with
their own beliefs it was like on Super
Bowl Sunday I had a joke and it was like
uh
I was like uh yeah countries that treat
women the worst have the best food yeah
that's a funny [ __ ] bit okay right so
it's like and it's weird like people
that have sought a bit who just like
read it made it [ __ ] go yeah and like
everything else trickled down after that
I'm sure you guys experienced this too
like one thing goes viral like when you
guys [ __ ] made Andrew Tate a
superstar remember that when now that my
whole [ __ ] algorithm is Andrew Tate
dude I can't even open Tick Tock with my
wife because every other video is like
[ __ ] need to be quiet
put their number on the forehead too
right
your guy's fault 100
when I did you had to spit out the
[ __ ] coffee if you didn't spill out
the coffee when I did uh my birthday
shows in Chicago
they were at an arena and on my birthday
they they played a super cut of people
wishing me birthday happy birthday
please and it was like it was like
mullaney Chappelle
like all these people and then Andrew
take and anyway well they went crazy and
also that week he was arrested for
trafficking women yeah I know like dude
and so you hear people go like oh my God
whoops yeah charges were dropped I want
to say Tate I know those charges were
dropped and you didn't do anything so I
didn't know the charges were dropped
yeah and I still wanted them on the
podcast yeah because it was like it was
just charges yeah you know and uh yeah I
don't know maybe he was talking a lot of
[ __ ] or whatever but he's [ __ ]
fantastic on Mike I mean he is so funny
and he's like to be honest that he is a
smart guy he's actually a very smart guy
super articulate has like he's Charming
he's charming and he actually gets that
it's a joke he gets that he's
entertaining views yeah and sometimes
you listen to him and you're like is he
[ __ ] right yeah I think yeah you're
like do I agree with this
woman I should know my place now here's
where I come in this is where the
Insight comes in with from Yanni
and I'm right people are hungry
for like some real funny
right some real talk some real funny
that they end up
enjoying these absolute buffoons like
him and Trump because they're the only
ones that go all the way they go all the
way so if you starve people enough and
keep throwing them this [ __ ] content
and these [ __ ] comedy specials and
these [ __ ] shows that people don't
want and you take all of like the Real
Entertainment from them
because of this whole
cool thing now to try to act like a
saint like you're you're better than
everyone and you're purer than everyone
this whole puritanical uh Zeitgeist that
we're dealing with now where everyone's
going yeah where'd you get those
stickers right do you know about to stay
there yeah it's because of that people
end up they get so starved they end up
embracing people like this as almost a
little bit of a [ __ ] you as a little bit
of a and these people are doing this to
fill a void because there's no void
there's a lack of diversity yeah and
most people won't go to this extent like
I won't go to this extent to get
attention right because I have integrity
but people like Andrew Tate and Donald
Trump don't so they will go to whatever
extent to sell for grandize they'll go
to they'll say whatever to do whatever
to make that the crowd pop okay when you
watch Donald Trump performing his
rallies he ain't trying to be thorough
and fair he's trying to pop the crowd
yeah Andrew Tate is trying to say the
most shocking [ __ ] to pop the crowd in a
reactionary way so they're both very
similar look they even both form stupid
universities yeah they both have their
universities they're warm-up comedians I
mean yeah they're trying to pop the
crowd
they're local comedians yeah they're
local comedians popping the crowd with
local references
you really think that he's he just needs
a hug that's what he needs his mother
needs to come back in his life like
let's be real yeah where is she someone
needs to have a word what do you think I
don't know I think she's it sounds like
he got under your skin a little bit oh
but he caught in the mice it sounds like
I think I'm not the one who's been
talking about him for four years bro
he's I'm literally this is the first
time I've ever talked about him I
couldn't give a [ __ ] about Andrew tit
really would you box him or celebrity
boxing well he is a fighting background
if if what I mean I see any comments to
me in my face yeah I would absolutely
punch him in the face but am I gonna
make effort to go running every morning
no
well first of all Tate's been around
forever really yes he was the one who
tweeted thing like Star Wars oh my God I
read that tweet dude yeah Tate's been
around a long time wow it tastes around
a long time yeah man he's been doing his
thing bro just grinding he deserves it
um
I am not defending
Andrew Tate's message don't get me wrong
I I'm not defending somebody who put
Hands On a Woman even if it was playing
like I saw the video it was a little
extreme y'all haven't seen the video
it's an extreme video even if it did
turn her on I I think it was really
extreme I'm not defending him saying
that women have to take responsibility
for things that happen to them against
their will I'm not defending that what
I'm defending is the opportunity to say
anything
that's you I don't if we can have
twerking videos you can watch a whole
porno on Twitter
you can watch a whole porno on Twitter
something that somebody has said
regardless if you agree or disagree with
it is doing more harm than seeing actual
porn my my my seven-year-old can go
access porn on Twitter
she can see the visual
she can see the visual of a man and a
woman doing it
but his words
his words are causing more harm than
that
listen to rap music man listen to rap
music like I'm old enough and I'm grown
enough and mature enough to know that
it's play play
a lot of this stuff these rappers rap
about is not real but kids can be
influenced by that
I don't feel like Andrew Tate
is any worse than a rapper
they're all personas they're egos
they're things that you create to become
popular every time I hear somebody who's
into him they go he's really big with
teenagers as if this isn't a mature
adult like you know Jake Paul was big
with teenagers this guy is Big with
anybody who has a brain to me yeah to me
this guy's big with everybody they took
all this yeah this guy's big with males
this guy's big with males it's just not
that's a huge sin now teenagers might be
into it because there's no outlet for
this right but who are you to silence
him because teenagers find him
motivational or whatever just dangerous
yeah because he's corrupting the Youth
of Athens they killed Socrates because
he was corrupting the Youth of Athens
Andrew Tate is not an outlier is my
point he's more of the normal prototype
of the person who gets famous now the
person who becomes president the person
who becomes Governor the person who
becomes state senator the person who
becomes congressperson he's it's more
the Prototype now the more outrageous
and outlandish you can be
the more attention you're gonna get
because they're suppressing everything
else they're suppressing everything else
so you either toe the line and you're a
perfect good soldier for
for the PC so there's no problems that
come to the company or the or whatever
the reputation you either toe the line
and pretend that you're a pure Angel and
you're for justice of everything
meanwhile you you're revving up your
private jet or whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing that makes you a hypocrite either
you pretend like you're that and say
nothing controversial or anything true
and and perfectly Pure or you're an
absolute [ __ ]
sociopathic Fame [ __ ] who will say or
do anything for attention like Andrew
Tate thank you
[Music]